and of course you'd be given with Jam
Master Jay that's awesome thank you
thank you welcome to another box kill an
episode of what's in the box man
I am Truman Capote
I am busulfan Feist amazing pick a
rider's name say I am John Schneider go
for IM TS alright welcome to another box
kill an edition of what's in the box
i'm truman capote I'm TS Eliot that
classy man and just like the poets
before us and the writers of those words
we are going to okay I lost the metaphor
we're gonna rip open [ __ ] boxes but
before that begins today you know what
happened today with a friend of ours no
well yeah actually kind of a front of
ours is involved
they had Zack Snyder the director of Man
of Steel and of course he directed you
know 300 and then he direct before that
he directed the Dawn of the Dead remake
and said but then he came in didn't a
steal then Batman V Superman then he did
Justice League but then they took
Justice League and away from him and
released a version with reshoots that
Joss Whedon oversaw and stuff like that
so for years now people they've been in
hashed it has been a hashtag online
called and released the Snyder cut
everyone's been saying release the
Snyder cut I talked about it on fat man
be on daph a couple times with Mark and
stuff Zack Snyder was doing a watch long
of Man of Steel this morning and he
announced that HBO max the new HBO app
that's coming out which is like they're
the version of Warner Brothers version
of Netflix okay so to have all the
Warner Brothers movies it'll have HBO or
have all that good stuff they are going
to have Zack Snyder's Justice League
they're gonna give him 20 to 30 million
to finish the movie that he was making
before they
took it away from so heating he never
gotten the footage he wanted to complete
it no they let him go yeah he wasn't
done yet and then they were like he had
a family tragedy so he stepped back from
the movie and they're like well we got
to keep this train going and then Joss
Whedon came on and then Joss Whedon
apparently according to Zach Zach said
we've only seen a quarter I think EXO
quote of what he intended so the rest of
it then meant that it was reshaped
remade and stuff and Josh brought a
bunch to it so we've never seen Zack
Snyder's version which spoilers if you
don't want to know this is rumored to
have the ends with again spoilers if you
want to hear this closer if you don't
want to hear this and this is where it
affects a friend of ours a friend of
ours it involves the death of Batman
Darkseid's in it dude Darkseid I just
saw him sitting on your [ __ ] table
yeah yeah
oh you're Darkseid doll show them how
happy you are
look at this [ __ ] dawn dawn dawn now
tell him release the Schneider Cup too
[ __ ] late they're releasing me all
right so big congratulations to Zack
Snyder of course man he's finally gonna
get to complete his vision but even
bigger congrats to like the fan base
that like made it happen a lot before so
they've announced 21 20 21 21 20 20 21
which is next year yeah it's gonna be on
HBO max and they're gonna break it up
into multiple parts and [ __ ] because
it's four hours or more oh and again
dark side isn't it so big news today on
the web can everyone hear us new you
want to be able to hear me beautifully
and maybe all we got raided thanks for
the raid thanks for the donation sorry
guys again this we were raided takeover
yeah again guys I appreciate you these
are going to be adjustments we have to
make we usually do this up at Kevin's
house so this is going to be I have to
figure out and hook up to Mike's I have
plenty of Mike's at play
cameras boy figure out his duel mic
situation I have a friend who said a
couple people offered to help and I
should have done that before he came so
it's my fault
rating his channel raid this room and
stick microphones all over the [ __ ]
place so that you could hear him clearly
I'll project you have a low voice so so
maybe I'll stand here until I open the
box or remove things or something but
we're good we are now ready kids if I
can open up that box man this is the
part of the show that everyone loves the
most we take this knife give me the
knife and we give it to our knifes man
man mr. Jason Mewes go ahead take over
now I get close to the mic for some
richer deeper sound if you're bored
while he's opening this box like it's
taking too much [ __ ] time I got to go
look at some other website on them on
the internet that Kevin Smith club.com
is the place to go kids okay alright we
got a card in here now let's see if this
is a picture of what we're about to see
we're about to see something sweet this
week's what's in the box kids is brought
to you by the good folks at level 52
studios level 52 I'm always like level
42 and they look 10 more level 52
studios sent us we got four boxes of
[ __ ] to share with you man and when I
say [ __ ] I mean the Primo good [ __ ]
level 52 is a company we're in business
with right now they're making Jay and
Silent Bob sculpture from Jay and Silent
Bob reboot just like not to be confused
with do you see [ __ ] Kurtzman's
iron Bob statue did you go to reboot
collection I think it is reboot
collection comp where Bob Kurtzman's
website you can see two-foot iron Bob's
that he's selling and stuff so level 52
is doing a Jay and Silent Bob leaning
against Quickstop statue I've seen it is
beautiful so you know the the the
prototype so these cats they saw us
opening boxes like we'll send you a
bunch of [ __ ] to open up it said score
and I said do we send it back and they
said no give it to Jason's fans
what and we're talking premium stuff
here today kids that's true he does get
first dibs but it's it's not like
normally we open toys or games level 52
does sculptures so we're gonna see some
high end high high and sculpture hired
me and you all know I'm high right now
so without further ado after all that
man thanks to the good folks 11 level 52
let's see what's in the box pull it out
I'll pull the box away I'm my upper body
strength is for [ __ ] so I don't know if
I can help here count of three let's get
that shiny plastic off and then see what
they got
oh my god it's a Frazetta
Legacy series I'm wearing it like a
sandwich board of roseto Legacy series
the Reaper bushel edition statue so this
is based on the Frazetta work the piece
by Frank Frazetta a lot of people
probably seen this of the Reaper death
himself on the back you can really see
it unless you want to open it even
better even better on a pale horse we're
gonna say it man that way whoever wins
it oh I know look at the clown oh look
how happy he is whoever wins it they're
gonna I see a little Logan through the
door a little kid chases co-host
coming in whoever wins these also wins
the additional bonus of it having been
touched by me and Jay are Co vadim it's
speaking of covert here's covert junior
self hi kid this is Logan Jason's
daughter guys I didn't want to say
anything but she is also gonna be given
away today we're gonna play a game of
marbles whoever comes in first I
stripped to her but you gotta pay for
shipping and handling because she's
getting big wait wait marble wait a race
wins a kid
I'll give you I'll give you a $40 for
the kid right now you don't have to do
no more Boris $40 I got me a new dog
she called me daddy the other day was
probably very embarrassing for her she
did in front of her father he cried and
stuff but I'm ready to have another kid
and for 40 bucks that's the cheap price
you get a feeder while she grows up
expensive yeah kiddo we're about to open
a box you want to see what's in the box
here we go all right man you can't miss
it
now what Jason was impressed by Jason
was all impressed by these straps and
they're really nice this is of course
styrofoam you get that any old place the
good folks at level 50 to put these
straps around the thing man and so
they're buckles like that could be used
in real life never happens I've never
seen anything like that where there's
straps
usually the styrofoam like has tape and
you gotta like cut the tape off and
stuff right here boom yeah this velcro
so let's okay 80s wallet out of it there
we go it comes right out all right I
hope that was okay I'll tilt it toward
me okay and you take the top good oh my
goodness look at the size of this guys
look at the size oh I mean I don't even
know if we should pull it out out
because I'm like a little scared but we
can and I'm not against because the
bottom it looks like it's separate Logan
it's okay are they vegan cookies maybe
maybe cake music come back come back
with cookies baby you could come back
with cookies please he was talking to me
that whole time he's a baby come back
with cookies all right good so I go able
to pull this out I was afraid it was
gonna
and we even it's still I thought it was
no work they could see the babies right
there alright perfect guys and there's
one more piece of course alright I got
it good there's even I'll keep it oh
it's a long sky you spin me right round
baby right yeah whoa there we go shot
yeah man
no make sure it's the boy solid yes and
then this is the weapon bro oh oh yes
caped I'm not gonna pull on that yes
look at us finger and [ __ ] up
oh here's the best part silica don't eat
it kids
no but save it for the silica wars that
are coming that is huge bro like dude
this it feels fantastic Joe Manganiello
would love this I'll let you do the
honors put in his let his arm look at
this quality item Louise a Joan watch
your head come here you know what while
you're there go forward again you could
take it right up to them and show them
detail oh it's heavy kids this is way
heavy it's made actual like I don't know
cement the shit's heavy beautiful that
is gorgeous man anybody out there for
Zetas fan any Frazetta fans in the hizzy
it's huge huge how much did you say it
weighs about 35 pounds so I would say
this is Debbie 25 pounds give one last
look man this is like the you know Home
Shopping Network don't let it fall apart
though I'd be so bad that is a beautiful
piece man from the good folks level 52
with this Frazetta card with the image
the original image on it over there
Wow really nice somebody's gonna get it
how you gonna decide who's gonna get
this so there is the marbles game wait a
sec right now to hype trains running oh
five trains happenin we're on level two
late I feel like this is like Home
Shopping Network the hype trains
happenin ladies and gentlemen we're on
level 2 and stuff if we could get to
level 3 we got four gifts so basically
one person what do you mean we got a
complete level 4 for us to give away
this sweet piece speak to this this is
the microscope speaking they are ya know
have to do that we don't have to do that
we I was just saying it would be fun
I've trained 24 percent kids kick up
that hype so we could get to level 3
takes us to the next prize that's when
we open this yes and right now somebody
who's on level 2 hype train who's
building right now if you start how do
you know who's responsible for the most
type yeah at the end someone gets to
choo-choo they become the hype conductor
so perhaps the hype conductor is the one
there you go hype gunda what clever
clever whoever becomes the hype
conductor gets this statue no I just
think at whenever it ends whoever I
believe I don't know guys I'm hoping
that it's not the end oh I believe it's
whoever gives the most constant
combination now the question is
hopefully it's not the last person I we
still I personally haven't figured let's
say 71% yes maybe it's moving now so you
guys could tell me is there only one
half conductor for the whole time we do
this I believe so you guys help me on
per level so oh my god we just jumped in
our level did we yeah we didn't agree on
someone gave five tier sub so thank you
for that where's all that Kevin you know
we don't hear the computer talking to
him that's my favorite part
yeah I love hearing
nine thousand when he's just like open
the pod bay doors kid this box look at
that what the percentage jumped again oh
yeah because someone just gave more
donations Oh hype indeed ladies and
gentlemen you know we're getting to the
next one now what they took us the next
level stab this [ __ ] box guys can you
tell me does anyone know is it the last
person to give bits or subs or whatever
to make the hype conductor or is it the
person who maybe processes the most or
something just want to get to the next
box but where it's sixty-four percent
level three on the hype train so I'm
gonna stop that hype choo choo as a
great man once said ladies and gentlemen
and that train is gonna take us right up
to level four and after level four we go
to level five getting ready for a
strange brew reference level 5 level 5
all right we're stabbing a box which
means we're back at it man as promised
Jason taken that blade like blade from
Masters of the Universe movie especially
and cutting into this [ __ ] box taking
its life this box once dreamed of living
but now dies in our hands as we open it
up once again level 52 providing us with
today's swag to send your way ooh this
is nice man okay so here's kind of what
the picture looks like let's see what
the box is oh [ __ ] the hype train is
taking us right to level 4 ladies and
gentlemen thank you for riding the hype
train this is Lucy and I need the
microphone this is the art of Icarus
hall and it's called
the witch it is a limited-edition statue
from the good folks at level 52 from the
cursed cursed and cruel line as you can
see that's basically Jason's nickname
all throughout high school and now
cursed and cruel CC we call him shall we
you know open this box and look what's
inside we shall need we need something
to get it higher right it's too low so
put some yeah it's like an empty box or
do you have all four [ __ ] home
improvements while this shows in the
middle of the show everyone's like we
were about to see the witch statue a
[ __ ] jerk you got him doing menial
labor look at me man I Otzi's gonna get
so mad I figured come in here bill you
should have been moving [ __ ] now give me
that little box because I'll use that as
a stage okay yeah we've opened the box
kids watch and it also has baby straps I
thought only the big boys baby straps
nobody puts Baby straps in the corner
woohoo the velcro sound means I'm
opening my sneakers getting ready to
work on how Reebok pumps and so much
better than then tape I feel yeah oh I
have you need tape like adhesive - yeah
it's live is better than cable it's a
good thing we are alive I was like it
came out of nowhere this piece is very
easy to pull out it's a wonder kids one
and done
let's take it's a little on the on the
oh oh
Lacey sad yeah good thing your kids not
in here okay let's slide that bad boy
for a second look at the detail on this
bad boy it's a lot of light hold on
autumn is like real lower I just turn it
to a little less no too hot down there
we go all right now they could see ooh
water - look at that
the eyes are sick look at her man she's
like what are you looking at and here
look at the detail on kids
cover your eyes cover your eyes cuz
you're about to see a little nudie well
we'll get in trouble on Twitch for this
sort of thing then the Linnet II get in
trouble for showing a little nipple or
something like that we don't want any of
those little initi troubles don't count
if it's just a sculpture I hope not look
at that that's a beautiful piece the
piece once again is called the witch it
comes to us from the good folks level 52
this is the rendering it comes from this
is the let's see if we could get her on
that angle and the water look at the
water she's in her hair draping on the
water and she's going like I was trying
to but yeah it's good
Oh number 133 of 300 so on the bottom of
course the good salts at level 52 have
it's the witch number 133 of how many
300 so this could be yours man the art
of Icarus Hall the witch limited edition
statue hypetrain is on level 5 everyone
was so happy to see that sculpted nudity
they're like heavens yeah we'll take you
to five all right so there it is the
witch man let's take a peek real quick
here can you pick up the death the pale
horse and let's see at the bottom
they've just the horse itself at the
base oh yes even the base is [ __ ]
dumped you can hang the base on the wall
just as a sign of only 160 of those
that's right kids so there's only a
hundred and forty-nine show him the
horse for the horse real quick
that only hunter tuo only what was it
169 149 I believe we just were so bad
with numbers 149 of 160 so whoever's
walking away with the reaper is walking
away with 149 of 160 whoever walks away
with the witch its 133 of 300 men and my
god that's a stunning piece I'm I am I
want to take that no you know what we'll
leave it for these good folks level 5 on
hypetrain sir we're at 13% that tells
you know what let's do a big box next
that'll get us to the next level that'll
get us all the way cuz don't we only
have a little time before the high train
alright kids and for that we're bringing
out the big guns man we want to see that
percentage grow we want to see that hype
train choo choo thanks to everybody
who's gotten Jason all the way up there
level 5 is only 86% away and how long do
we have to get there come on kids get us
there we can't miss the station man
we're so damn close we need to cut this
a little bit more watching it here comes
a knife oh just in case okay we won't
open it yet because we'll wait a few
there's a minute left kids there's 15
percent 17 18% 19% 1 minute to get to
level 5 man this is when twitch has me
right in his [ __ ] grip man like oh my
god are we gonna make it this shit's
like Vegas I'm gonna roll all the bones
man and I'm gonna spin all the wheels
and I'm gonna hope that we get oh my god
33 percent we're gonna will we beat it
40 40 seconds to get 65% oh my god must
I take out a nipple I'll take one out
and I'll put it on two glass if you get
us there
in 30 seconds we only have 30 seconds 30
seconds or else we missed the hype train
level 5 kids once we do that we're gonna
show you what's inside it oh my god I
just got a glance at what's inside it is
worth [ __ ] saying somebody gonna win
[ __ ] you've got 14 seconds we're never
gonna make it twelve seconds ten six
five four three two at 61% excellent job
well not quite excellent but pretty damn
great level for such strong support
level five completed it says we finished
level five you did it kid you're the
[ __ ] heroes wait Stone enjoyed [ __ ]
the choo-choo masters up from now
somebody who's watching these sort of
things make sure we know who the
choo-choo conductor is and what is what
does the conductor do it just shows that
he gave two train conductors that's
great
very very sweet remark oh we never
thought about that if somebody is
somebody out there keeping track of this
so yeah and we're at a thousand of
viewers right now thanks for tuning in
ladies and gentlemen Kevin Smith here
with Jason Mewes and we are what's in
the boxing it we just reached level five
on the hype train I don't know what any
of it means but I gotta tell you it's
[ __ ] exciting stuff just like Vegas
in one room man lights whistles buzzers
no computer voice today that was the
[ __ ] part that we're really missing
out does anyone have a dollar to donate
because I want to see if it's working if
it's that oh is that my favorite part of
the show I love when the computers like
Kevin everything you do in life is smart
and good tell your wife she is wrong I'm
like thank you twitch
and we can we test that out right now
does anyone have a dollar we didn't even
have to leave Jersey for you to walk up
to people and be like anybody got a
dollar you got a dollar you did that
[ __ ] in highlands I saw somebody said 20
bits would we hear that 20 bits little
man put that [ __ ] in my hand the bits
are working now the bits when somebody
gives a buck or something then we hear
the slowly learning kids okay okay oh
we're back that means that you're
dancing well they will it's seven and
Jason are cool
you gave five bucks for that holy [ __ ]
I gave five bucks I would have been like
Kevin's cool Jason's an [ __ ] because
you would have earned every penny of
that five bucks but as the boy said
thank you okay we promised to you kids
that the hype train was going to go and
roll this is the next day
and then tell me WI o mu WI o oh we all
we all right next piece o is that
someone else calling in every time jason
says that somebody talks here okay Maxie
Chu Chu and Tre marks the one that want
regardless remark isn't the leader in my
on my twitch for giving out gifted subs
overall may I make a suggestion
visit gifting five sup but yes let them
pick like a mock pick the one he likes
and then stone can pick the other one
bang and then there's two more to get
out - yes okay this is called once again
from our good folks at level 52 who
showed us the Reaper and we live to tell
about it
showed us the witch and we saw some
naked boobies now somebody else's now
the computer is gonna talk I'm learning
it damn it stop maybe I did go back to
back it might kill that so we don't get
to hear what they said this next piece
ladies and gentlemen is is entitled
busted the art of Kirk Kurt my bad paps
team
yeah I'd [ __ ] you back you're always
right is always right oh my god do you
[ __ ] her as well here we go
turning this around looks like we might
have some ranges ladies ladies that's
awesome thank you all right here we go
the level 52 straps mean one thing
quality and good times why ripped open
before hold on hours of entertainment
Thank You world
okay and now somebody else has come yeah
starting yeah well we got a horse Sean
the horse but those that came in late
the good folks at level 52 has provided
us with a Frazetta death
you know the Reaper on a pale horse so
there's your donkey show it's coming up
once again someone's put in a mom and
put a tip in our tip jar his tip jar do
miss you love you as well all right here
we go while we got a chance let me tilt
it back
holy [ __ ] guys look at this this is one
piece I think guys it's a bus great work
boys Thank You Chi Chi su Chi booties
indeed wow look at this man
mr. paps team did us a solid we gotta
get this to like Joe Rogan sitting it is
but you come - what's in the box - get
some head ladies and gentlemen we're
gonna give you some head look at that
man look at that
see the detail the like they're like
slime and stuff almost on
[Music]
no prowl it's entirely my husband I love
you guys thanks for being awesome
thank you that's number five guys eight
a 150 Domo Domo this all right guys give
it up after lawless on the starting line
why'd you throw it out and get a sense
it here as well more there's one more
cuz this I could see this as lawless
after this guys give it one section we
can talk about the more that we're
talking it's happening now all the time
which is something we want right Joe
Rogan's got a big like American Werewolf
looking werewolf in his studio this
would look nice right in it it's very
nice the tongue this is the hound
yeah zero number 82 it's the eight
number eight of like one of 150 but also
the tongue looks like it's like and
wedding [ __ ] we got the two big pieces
I think trademark like I said traumatic
stone ninja when Kevin leaves and we're
towards the end I could sit down you
guys I can pick it out we'll figure that
piece out I think trademark you know a
trademark you keep you first pick and
then whatever's left we'll go to stone
ninja for the four pieces that were
opening up and then the last two will
figure out there's one more box to open
ladies gentlemen what's in the box we
are up to 1100 people watching on J
stream
the best part just began somebody's
talking to us man looks like it's is it
from the top or the bottom
I get so mentality we are we're gonna do
that on Monday talking to the Sunday
Sunday we're gonna do our normal like
maybe well play some old games like
retro games
Donkey Kong miss pac-man we're gonna
figure that out for a couple more
marlborough or we should take that all
the way to the end of the game I hear
there's a quick stop at the end I did
alright so there you have it maybe we'll
play more broadly again and do some more
chatting and then the next night will 8
at night on Monday we're going to watch
some movies that were going to start for
fresh from the beginning clerks guys
very sweet
workplace comedies have always existed
even before clerks but workaholics yeah
I feel like they owe us a little bit of
money 5% or something like that but
wonderful kids alright we got a box it's
tiny kids look at this but there's only
one way in and out of this room and it's
with a [ __ ] knife to the guts so here
comes mr. Jason Mewes to stab the [ __ ]
out of this box tell you something you
you would have to really bring the hype
train for some of that we'd have to get
up to like level 10 before I'd be like
all right I will jerk off me and you
will jerk off you while we hold each
other's arms as per zack and miri and
we'll pull this i wonder i don't know if
i'm a top or a bottom what do you think
would you like to take or get would say
he's dead I would think he would be the
top the giver seems like a lot of work
oh my god this is I'm sorry guys I'm
actually gonna keep this one but it's
okay what do you mean the good folks at
level 52 have provided us with this it's
God of War and it's Atreus toys limited
edition collectible figurine set number
335 of 750 man level 52 and Santa Monica
studios
you seem interested in this why don't
you open it up and tell us what it is I
mean you're so interested that you're
like oh I'm keeping it
you're like Eliot Nietzsche I'm keeping
him I wanted I want all of it at that
number he stabbed it the box is open and
now we're seeing it taken out our pieces
raised gentlemen hey man at UTI that was
yours like clean I told you to keep your
pisser clean that wasn't on me a little
bit of Delaney these are nice so it's
from the game God of War now I'm not a
huge god of war I haven't played a whole
lot of it but I do know the game and
I've played the game it's an awesome you
know that's why I had the ps4 logo on
the front the Omega which is like
Darkseid oh my god a war that's their
symbol so here's a little Archer and
who's the other guy
this is the actual this is the actual
main guy right and this is so anyone
else here boy is any
here a huge God of War player he said
this is his son
Oh Atreus father and son says yeah it is
was it called Atreus on the box and
there's look at the detail it feels
wooden like it's carved out of wood but
of course it's made of this stuff yeah
very much like large chess pieces is
there more than these guys in the
collection there's more of the
collection in August yeah we love we
love animals thank you
you get these pieces not from Jay he's
gonna keep them and you could play Jay
and Silent Bob reboot he's Jay the son
Bob I mean that's between you and your
God ladies and gentlemen I have no idea
how much would you take for that shirt
we're doing our but this has become the
Home Shopping Network
you wanna ride the monitor I wanna sit
on the seat if i sat on the speaker that
would have made me not gorgeous pieces
ladies and gentlemen from our good folks
and friends all right level 50 to thank
them for sending us this stuff to open
on what's in the box
and then for some of you you're gonna
walk away some [ __ ] so now we know that
you're two dudes got the two big pieces
Trey mark I think you'll pick first and
stone ninja could pick and if so ninja
wants the smaller the girl item it was a
walk so you guys get totally and then
there'll be one piece left over that
piece we'll figure out a way to get rid
of it I thought that was a great idea
for the the hype and I appreciate
everyone who didn't who chipped in sub
gifted subs and donated and all that
stuff didn't get the prize you're not
kidding and when he says he appreciates
it no [ __ ] like when we're done
later on he talks about it where he's
just like those people are so nice to
you then he was explaining like they
give two bits to give the money man it's
so we ran out of [ __ ] to open ladies and
gentlemen but boy did we open some cool
[ __ ] thanks to our friends at level 50
to go check out their website see if you
like any of their stuff maybe buy
something if you can't afford it in
these times if not at least we got to
see some cool [ __ ] so wait two people
are getting the one who's gonna get the
third I don't know yet so Trey market
pick up um when we're done here I'll sit
in front of what's the criteria for
giving away the third Oh well usually I
just play usually when it's like you're
playing a game as to this yeah you see
play marbles to give away the third one
I think marbles I don't know I think we
should do something fun more fun I was
safe runner hand jobs more fun for that
third piece because it is a stature it's
not a board game and it's not like a
action figure which are awesome but
those are like alright we have ten of
those so here's marble game Orville
because the marble game is everyone puts
play in that's in the chat and
automatically links them to a marble and
then the marble goes through a maze and
the first marble to get through and it
goes through like a gauntlet so someone
will be in first place but then they
fall and get stuck on like a tree and
these are digital marbles yeah they're
right through that it's on the game
itself it's fun all right there it is
man get your marbles out and he's gonna
give you some [ __ ] to play with yeah
1200 almost 1300 people watching this on
your stream right now on Jays Twitch
anything you want to give him before we
go out we talked about the beginning the
show congratulations to Zack Snyder and
all comic book movie fans particularly
of course Justice League fans they're
gonna see the real Justice League Zack
Snyder's Justice League in 2021
that gives us a reason to live through
this quarantine nightmare ladies and
gentlemen if we could just survive
colvett they're gonna reward us with
Justice League after we pay them for HBO
max you see how that works
what do you close in [ __ ] no I'm sorry I
was X I was facing out thinking about so
it's different than HBO go but that
doesn't matter it is different HP l max
is a brand new service I think HP I'll
go in HBO now might be absorbed into HBO
Mac so it's all one-stop shopping but
it's beyond HBO it's like not just the
stuff in HBO it's all the Warner Bros
stuff has Warner Brothers HBO same
business and stuff so yeah it's gonna be
cool man but it's cool especially right
now they did the smart thing they heard
the audience the audience is like we pay
you to [ __ ] see that all right put
your money where your mouth is now
everybody better order HBO max if they
want to see it also follow Kevin Smith
Club guys Kevin Smith click join that
Kevin Smith he has lots of original
stuff he's been doing him and I are
starting to do stuff together here are
my twitch and on his Facebook our
YouTube Facebook which will Monday
that's where we do the free stuff
watching movies we're gonna start Sunday
we're gonna play some games in the
afternoon probably keep playing mall
brawl till we beat that then starting on
Monday night yeah we're gonna watch
we're still figuring out what it's
called
I like Jay and Santa Bob watch
themselves well the one dude has and
again this is
this isn't a push it but sorry guys we
could still also guys if you want if you
have Amazon Prime you can follow
subscribe me with em use for free on
Twitch Prime if you activate your twitch
prime Amazon Prime alright so sorry
sorry guys I'm trying to find look at
all your of course messages I know what
is your number
I do like 10,000 no no no it's not that
many but sorry a dude here wrote to me
and started to working it was like show
me your dick and he sent you a dick pic
is that what this day is about your ego
Mike I'm sorry sorry here look at that
so he said just the case if you like me
I do love it movies I like and he's
already got like an idea for that so
that's an idea he can like say they
can't wait to Jay and Silent Bob what's
in the box so he could send I was doing
Sunday at 1 to 5 and again to a
quarantine [ __ ] game show stop I love
it I love what I get to do it out to
Jeff this camp this camp
hey what up Jeff is only one camp I'm
going to this summer Jeff this camp oh
yeah what else we got Jay and Silent Bob
played with their movies welcome oh
happy birthday Jim girl happy birthday
birthday Jim girl true harm says I fart
in a bug birthday normal I'm gonna go
back to that Kevin Smith Club
ladies and gentlemen which is my house
around the around the bend over there
it's like I'm really not that far away
from here and you just cleaned your
office and you're starting to get your
man cave going for your club oh is that
my man cave going my friend I'm cleaning
it finally [ __ ] for you can move
around and I've been uncovering a lot of
cool stuff there it is a tomorrow night
if you're into watching [ __ ] I'll be
doing fat man beyond with Mark Barnard
and on my stream and and at this scum
and villainy Cantina watch that and
we're gonna talk all about the Snider
cut oh yeah you could smell it oh yeah
so yeah guys come back well I'm not
leaving yes you don't leave I'm gonna
stream still guys for another hours
about an hour and a half or so I mic the
styrofoam home and build a little fork
made of on hop I'm gonna set up my Star
Wars figures and [ __ ] build some
trenches pull out my hat at my snow
Walker and this is gonna be the rebel
base that would be awesome be like han
Solo and Leia running through these
tunnels and [ __ ] he's like come with me
and [ __ ] he brings it on Millennium
Falcon and c-3po is like can I go build
forts with Jay and Silent Bob that is
may the force be with you that's coming
that's our show on Tuesday thanks for
hanging out ladies and gentlemen for
what's in the box I am level 52
Chewbacca and I am level 52 Yoda Neko
means sound like Yoda those two
characters were rarely spent time ago
the natural answer was on solo but
regardless whoa whoa in the one movie
uh-huh Chewie is the one who saves Yoda
when he's like order six six six
sixty-six yeah movies but yes you're
absolutely right [ __ ] me in the mouth
Chewie and Yoda were best [ __ ]
friends so it was a winning response
I didn't sound like Yoda but I brought
it back I'm so sorry that I [ __ ] on his
Yoda that's it man I'm gonna turn you
over back to this cat [ __ ] I'm still
here but yeah
domina just my business so how about we
do yeah so let me show him the cool
transition and then I'm gonna be back to
play more I'm hanging out with to watch
the cool transition is this it
bye everybody thanks for watching man
that Kevin Smith Club calm
oh what a cool transition that was but
you're not ending
[Music]
you